now to some tragic and unexpected news
in professional football police say
former nfl star damaris thomas was found
dead in his home last night he was just
33. thomas was a five-time pro bowler a
super bowl champion with the denver
broncos and a likely future hall of
famer he caught 63 touchdowns in his
career but it was this 80 yard touchdown
pass from tim tebow that was his most
iconic it came in deborah's overtime
wild card win over the pittsburgh
steelers in 2011. in a statement his
former quarterback peyton manning said
dt was a better person than he was a
player and he was a hall of fame player
that tells you how good of a person he
was he treated my kids like they were
his own
he was there for every teammates charity
event
thomas only retired from the nfl last
june
here's part of that announcement i'm a
retired denver bronco
i'm honored i'm grateful uh i'm
appreciative
there's so many things i can say
and um i'm just happy to say
i'm done and it did me well
it didn't mean well wow seems like a
beautiful human being and we don't know
anything more about what might have
happened unexpected and tragic is a way
to describe it 33 years old did you know
him nate i i met him on a few occasions
he was a really good player yeah but he
was uh a better man
you know being a professional athlete
you can get caught up in the glitz and
the glamour and it feeds into your ego
and you walk around as an exaggerated
version of yourself it was almost like
he was the opposite
he was reserved he walked around
everywhere with this humility
that he wore like a strong cologne
so it's
it's unfortunate we hear these stories
about individuals that you know and have
run across
that uh i pass away so young yeah it's
another reminder again about the
fragility of life yeah would have turned
34 on christmas day well